does anyone in here work in the medical
profession by any chance
yeah what do you do you're a what sorry
a ward sister well done that's a great
job
i always wanted to work in the medical
profession i wanted to be a doctor
or maybe if you'd worked harder
you're fat i am so i go to the doctor
and i tell the doctor he's like why are
you so fat and something
i said that'd be funny most guys try to
lose weight right
but i try to become a huge fat guy
so anyways he said that's not funny
that's he says that's alarming
i i think it's funny that is funny yeah
it's pretty funny
but he said that it's it's it's quite
alarming and that
um i'm in a lot of a lot of trouble
and i said well i think it's funny and
i'm the comedian
so you know so i said let's agree to
disagree and then you know what he said
and i say that a lot yeah you do you say
that constantly yeah that's my out
that's your especially when i was
younger especially when i'm wrong right
i'll argue an argument i guess we have
to agree to disagree
anyways this [ __ ] he goes no
i go what i thought you had to agree to
disagree the customer's always wrong he
goes i will not agree to this
is the truth sorry he goes i will not
agree to disagree i will disagree
i said what's the distinction i don't
understand isn't agreeing to disagree
the same
essentially as disagreeing no says he
it's not
he says if i agree to disagree he goes
it gives more credence to your side of
the argument he goes
it sounds like we have two separate uh
arguments
both of which have merit and then i
are i'm saying that
some of your points are valid and you're
saying some of my points are about but
he's saying that
he's saying no he's saying that would be
like he's saying that would be as
unconscionable for him
as to agree with a uh holocaust
revisionist
and i said are you gonna bring up the
[ __ ] holocaust every time you give me
a physical
this guy he's got a tattoo he's 96.
i know his backstory i treat most things
in life it's like i never go to the
doctor's
unless it's right that is sensible that
is very good advice no
that's brilliant advice listening never
go to the doctors
unless it's really bad but that's why a
lot of people you know
um die because they don't want to bother
the doctor or they're mildly embarrassed
or they don't know
um symptoms but go to the doctor if if
if you're not sure about someone like
you were terrified to go and have your
prostate
still not been not doing it why not i
wish you won't talk about it because now
suzanne will listen to this
and she'll go oh yeah you haven't been
and start dragging it up again
but why are you worried about a little
uh
a qualified doctor
what are you talking about they pop
their finger up that's what i mean
though
why why are they still using the index
finger
what would you prefer the forefinger or
the thumb would you
just put the camera up straight away no
they don't need to they pop the finger
up
feel that the prostate isn't swollen and
wiggle it around a little bit i'd be a
a back passage i don't think
they they need to do are you embarrassed
are you embarrassed about being in the
room with your trousers around your
ankles and little fellas popping a
little bit yeah why
and the other thing is it's not just
that is it so you go in there they check
your art out on that which to me is the
most important thing because that's what
keeps you going in it
you've got to go there you're sat on the
bus stressing out thinking oh
in less than half an hour i'm going to
have a finger up
they check your heart they probably
check your testicles and then what's up
with that they take their schools yet
but it's all building and you've sat
there going oh soon that'll that will be
happening yeah
that's what puts me off so if they just
came round when you're asleep
suzanne just let them in there right and
they crept up and went
bang you know what you're doing i just
don't understand why they don't teach
you how to do it yourself
imagine you squatting in a corner with
whatever you follow to the other finger
at the ass going
it seems to be all right carl you don't
understand the phrase the stitch in time
saves night i don't think you should be
doing any kind of
invasive medical research in your own
human body
but but then who knows what trouble
you're going to cause no but then you
would get stuck
yeah you would get stuck your fist would
be up your own arc
i had to go to the eye doctor i hadn't
been the eye doctor in 20 years man but
i can't see
so i went to the eye doctor it was
horrible man man they well they had all
these tests that you do
and which were fine but they had this
one test at the end which i never heard
of
it's called the glaucoma test so they
shoot a puff of air into your eye
i never heard of that doctor's like yeah
mr hawkins we're gonna do the glaucoma
test on you now okay
what we're gonna do we're gonna put your
chin in the rest you're gonna look
through that hole
and what we're gonna do and we're gonna
shoot a puff of air
into your eye
why
we don't know just what they tell us to
do in high school
like all right you're the doctor like
put my chin in the rest i'm like all
right i looked at a hole all right
are you gonna
did i do it wrong
do i have glaucoma
no you're fine here's your eyeball back
it's shot out in the parking lot
folks that's the first time in my life i
had a puff hair go into my body and out
of my body at the same time
overrated underrated for this week uh
these are great by the way overrated
nurses
i gotta go be careful on this i have
some friends who are nurses here uh
my wife and i just had our first baby
and she was in labor for a day and a
half
day and a half in labor god bless her um
i noticed as we went through about four
shifts of nurses that every single one
of them at some point
managed to cram in how difficult their
job was
and how they're underpaid have to work
long hours and don't get any respect
my wife is in excruciating pain and i
haven't slept for two
days so perhaps you feeling the need to
nail yourself to a cross
every time you carry your bloated ass
down the hall to dole out an aspirin is
falling on deaf ears
jesus um we were right outside the
nursing pen when those hogs
sat around
[Laughter]
those hogs what a great word
sat around the whole night cackling at
[ __ ] jokes and knocking down
crispy creams as they patted each other
on the back
granted i would have blown my brains out
if i was stuck on the graveyard shift
with that hurt all night
but can we give this guy a round of
applause for the amount of different
creative ways he's been able to call
these women fat
bloated hogs and
heard you have a future in writing my
friend
um anyways i blow my brains out if i was
stuck on the graveyard shift with that
hurt all night
but it didn't exactly seem like the
toughest job in the world
what really killed me is how they would
go on to [ __ ] about the doctors
and how they were all how the doctors
were all arrogant
and don't know anything i really felt
like telling them i get that
both you and the doctor have papers
hanging on the wall but the difference
is
that his are medical degrees from
stanford and princeton
and yours is an honorable mention from a
community college
and a ziggy cartoon from 1989.
let's just say md gets the tie and move
on
what makes them overrated here we go
let's get to the point is that you can't
call them out on their [ __ ]
because although they don't do much they
can make your life
miserable while you're there so instead
of going off on them
i sent my dad out to refill their slop
bucket
with a couple dozen chocolate glazed
underrated doctors i know they get
respect already but they deserve more
no exaggeration we spoke with the doctor
for 10 minutes
she came in looked at our charts did
some stuff on a few
machines then laid out three choices and
recommended one
45 minutes later we had a healthy baby
girl
um dude that's [ __ ] hilarious but i i
gotta defend nurses and uh
they do work their asses off and that
type of [ __ ] but uh i think a lot of it
was you're emotional
but you you are making some point now if
they're sitting out there cackling about
[ __ ] jokes eating donuts
then uh jesus christ did you deliver
your
[ __ ] baby in a in a precinct
that sounds like a bunch of cop jokes to
me